pirro qu'est-ce qu'il vous faudra pas le
moins ça te plaît alors répondeur c'est
pas vrai c'est bien ton frère ça parce
que c'est pas ton frappe à ta wii
on commence pas le déjeuner de mon
mariage sans mon frère c'est pas comme
si je ma mairie tous les jours
bon en même temps sa troisième fois ah
ouais
et 14 ans quand j'ai vu que les galères
franchement j'étais désolé je suis ici
heureux pour mon frère et sa femme sont
plus jamais tu veux parce qu'imaginez
toile et ferait pas la tête si tu as des
as en arrière je te dis non sa femme
bien des coudes franchement sandra
sahara
si j'ai quelque chose d'important à vous
dire j'ai rencontré quelqu'un est si
heureuse je n'ai pas beaucoup cette
phrase
je vous dis que c'est amoureuse qu'est
ce que j'ai dit tout en terre moi je
pouvais pas faire autrement oui
non mais ça va il saura ça change rien
la lame a dit que vous êtes rencontrés
rouleau moi je divorce est hélas très
bonne avocate et même qu'il va se
remarier et qui met sa mère j'ai tout
donné pour cette pour être apte
je vais faire quoi rennes là vous pouvez
vous jeter gdra quelques-uns suis un
connard pardon je signe mon stylo
l'auto son frère c'est pas du tout le
genre de gars qui va dire qu'il a un
problème pourquoi tu m'as rien je ne
suis pas qu'un opticien
je suis ton grand frère merde
[Musique]
ça joue tout le temps grand frère avec
toi m'ont fait une vraie maman pour eux
[Musique]
il n'aurait pas quelque chose à nous
annoncer par hasard la famille va
s'agrandir
ah bon et qui
à khewra aussi tu peux faire des gaffes
[Musique]